- Eight.
Come on, nine.
Push it, baby.
You are a god. Come on.
- This is Chase's assistant.
I'm--I'm bringing him in now.
- Oh, we need
two more minutes.
We're trying to get
his pecs to pop.
- He's 13.
I don't think
his pecs can pop.
And why does
he suddenly need pecs?
- Because, Brooke, look,
we did sweet. We did gay.
Now he's a [bleep] boy.
- Ew, don't call him that.
- Come on, clench.
If you crap, I want it
to have to fight its way out.
Come on.
- Ugh, this guy sucks.
I can't believe
I have to have sex with him.
- You don't.
- No, he's very dom
and very hot,
so, unfortunately, I do.
- Good, all right.
- Guys, we need ChaseDreams.
And make sure
he's wearing the bracelet.
- This is Chase's assistant.
I'm bringing him now,
and we actually
decided necklace.
- Okay, here we go.
And five, six...
- I love having a walkie.
- Two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
One, two, whip, pull,
yes, yes.
- Oh, shit.
- Awesome.
- How you doing?
You excited?
- Oh, I'm so nervous
I could barf.
I just hope I don't
mess up tonight.
- Don't be nervous.
You literally can't mess up
"Watch What Happens Live."
- Yeah, well, at least
I'll have you next to me.
- Well, behind you, but yeah.
It'll be nice to hang out.
I feel like you've been so busy
since you moved here.
- Okay, I gotta run.
Ugh, you're so lucky you don't
have to wear clothes tonight.
- Yes, I feel very, very lucky.
Hi, um, I'm looking
to get jacked fast.
- Do you have
a gym membership?
- No, uh, but it's kind of
an emergency.
I'm gonna be the bartender on
"Watch What Happens Live"
'cause, just--it's good
to be seen.
- Okay, yeah, no, totally.
I did that last week.
- Oh, are you
an actor too?
- Yeah.
Well, no.
I met Andy at a rag & bone
and he just asked me.
- Oh.
- Good, good,
good, good, good.
Okay, you're chillin'
on your car.
Good, yeah, you're loving
your watch.
Put it a little closer
to your face.
Okay, like,
but do it naturally.
Hold it like
you'd hold your watch
close to your face
on your car.
Good.
- ♪ Even the walls
should stink ♪
- Oh, my God.
Brooke Dubek?
Genevieve Kim.
We used to dance together
at SAB.
- Oh, hi, yeah.
- Are you dancing
in your brother's video?
I thought you stopped
after you broke your ankle
a long time ago.
- Yeah, I did.
I, um, I'm actually here
because I'm--
I'm his--I'm his manager.
Yeah, I'm a really
big-time manager now.
- That is so cool.
- Yeah, my life is very cool.
- We need Chase's assistant
to set.
We've got a snack emergency.
- Oh, I don't know why
they gave this to a manager.
[radio clatters]
Anyway, how are you?
I saw on Facebook
you did a gig in Paris.
- Yeah.
- So fun.
I bet it was really rainy,
though.
- No, no, it was
really, really sunny.
- Anybody got eyes
on Chase's assistant?
I repeat, we have
a snack emergency.
- Where is this dumb bitch?
- Brooke, why is your walkie
on the ground?
They're calling you on set.
We have a snack emergency.
- I'm gonna head back
to holding.
The choreographer
is a disaster.
Just be glad you don't have to
deal with that anymore, right?
- [laughs weakly]
"Be glad you don't have
to deal with that anymore."
Asshole.
[intense music]
- [exhales]
♪ ♪
- Pardon me, sir.
Nope.
♪ ♪
I think this one's broken.
It's been one minute?
- You have a great day
as well.
Finished already?
- Huh?
No, uh, no.
No, I just thought
there might be some, uh--
I thought there might
be heavier weights out here.
Hi, hello.
Um, but I'm just gonna
make do with the lighter ones
that are inside.
[clears throat]
- You hiding from
the weights too?
- Care bear.
- Lance?
- Okay, we don't know what
some of these products
are actually gonna be yet,
so just pretend
you're watching the coolest
movie that you've ever seen.
Now it's a scary movie.
Now it's a funny movie.
Now it's a dating website.
Now it's a Christian
dating website.
Yep, all right.
Now it's "Chicago Med."
Now "Chicago Fire."
Now "Chicago PD."
Good, one of those
should work.
[bell rings]
God, I love money.
- Check the gate
on whatever that was.
Turn around.
Let's get Chase to wardrobe.
- [laughs]
- Excuse me, Genevieve.
- Oh, hey, Brooke.
I was just telling the girls
how we used to dance together.
- I know
what you were saying,
that you're so much
better than me
because I'm my little brother's
assistant and you're still
dancing in Paris
while it's sunny.
Well, guess what?
I might not be a dancer
anymore, but I'm happy, yeah,
because I have purpose,
I have direction,
and most importantly,
my toes are back to normal.
- So you take your--
- [sobs]
- Oh, my God.
Your toes are that bad?